UNIFIL in law like all art daily
press briefing online and live we come there
weekend of the line participate
videoconference and the group i think of
the left guen jean pierre decool meeting
of the stone age and 10 km
once and morning three young
sports talents  and coaches of beit
parliament we say hugo vide nineteen
vaccination strategy and fire of russia
via government sir florine kitsu
crystalline music president
economic and social like a
single-seater fortune on weekdays gently
action long presentation beating
four classes thank you laughter in the
afternoon everyone when  as you know
the commission adopted its
european plan to beat cancer on wednesday is
today friday we are adopting the
senior plan to a strategic issue
for applications using
ionizing radiation for medical purposes
this action plan constitutes the first
initiative of  monitoring of the european plan
to include concerns the samir
abdallah plan  that
radiological and nuclear technologies continue
to have positive effects on the
health of citizens of the european union
to give you some figures and
approximately 500 million image sessions
hours of radiological images each
year in europe there are  10 million
for nuclear medicine and one and a
half million for
radiotherapeutic treatments the st samir plan has
defined actions and measures in three
key areas secure
the supply of radioisotopes
the medical improve radiological quality and
safety in the
medical field and  facilitate
facilitate innovation and technological development
of medical applications
using ionizing radiation from the
public today a
press release
a moment they were fact
sheet on the samira plan
you will find in the daily news
thank you thank you very much
team for  this announcement in addition in
impeccable French
david killed the first qu  estion jean
louis david carretta thank you eric david
carretta monday calais raid it's a
foreign policy issue because
we just attended a
press conference in moscow between the lot
representatives and
foreign minister lavrov
well i leave it to everyone  the judgment
on how the press conference was
but the Slovak or accused
the European Union of several things
of not respecting human rights
freedom of the press democracy
the rights of Catalans to demonstrate
he disputed the fact that
the  results from the French
and Swedish laboratories on the attack on
mr navalni and many other
things do you accept all this
and these accumulations
thank you thank you peter can't be with
us today at the 2010 meeting and
so I give the floor to nabil yes
hello david and thank you for your question
I think that the high representative
was was and is present at this
press conference  so it's not me to come
and interpret the words and the answers
of the high representative
with regard to human rights
it has also been very clear that
the european union is very very close
and very firm in relation to  everything that
is human rights whether in
russia or gold of russia with
regard to alexei navalni i think that the
representative was also very clear
in his condemnation of alex and narain in
valmy i also remind you  the
european union and the position of the
european union in relation to alexei navalni
and therefore i do not think it is up to
me today to say or to
interpret actions or to interpret a
press conference which has just
to take place
thank you for regulars a follow-up question
yes thank you and thank you to myla for your
answer
but my question was not on the
words of the haurat pressure as
we heard them my question for sure
the accusations  what minister lavrov
did to  the european union on the
lack of respect for human rights
and serge hefez
all over there on the double standards of
the media rattan on the results of
the french labs swedish is
all that acceptable to you is
that what you  accept these accusations
but david I'm sorry I understand your
questions but you can't
ask us to respond to
remarks made in a
press conference which has just ended
when the high representative was dense is
in this conference
it is simply absolutely impossible
for us also at the service of the
spokesperson to comment on a
press conference which has just taken place in the
presence of the representative vis
vice-president so we are unfortunately not going to
engage in a
debate on this  I believe that you
know very well what our
policies are, the values that the E
ropean Union respects, the mechanisms that
t puts in place to ensure that
these values can be can be respe
ted and this is what founds our e
ropean identity olive
in strasbourg limits with senna
barney 2010 shy his entourage did h
explain the horiz
n sometimes you comment we say expla
n vic and taking place  facing the
crash by picking up mesto navalni
the enemy said that mr navalni should not
be inc resound eyes continue to
call for his emitted conditional willis
crowd investigations a tourist
poisoning and democratic society
political pluralism
opposed to ours
silent hill 1 10-1 acceptable  is
unacceptable alexeï navalni is behind
bars in resumption hockey in title meet
in die circumstances and all claws
of wrong next dates or
accept situation gray gold where he is
we do not date 7 guillou continued to
have claude contact with mr evans esteem
of youppi  new new new river to
chouhada coming forest made only
one record to this involvement actions
asia our and sheaths of visi  your is not
over yet rules presented on this
date of discretion corinne can you have
seen from almost in france is our
trashy daily life
yes but this work estimates the volume in the
cold
this team 2min physical ignorance
concerning lot meeting nine years 2005
and 2006
c  he's a politician anyone at the
limit is present for tics to
president alexeï navalni esbl aat
current route and drug gif it's
rank channelit you're young you have we do grifo
this interview david
[Music]
it's a villa in the name not tubes to a
tweet and watten asus eee from asus is
pounded press includes this very
very closely and wazekwa young 3 to 6
of its fries or cubed three ears
to  ndèye guèye on stage two positions at the
10th representative enough to your
review if you follow you would see world
press complaints following this test date
of the jo veepee explained date of position
off in cube at west bay what is needed the
wing of layton and th  e last
administration of these
situation youngsters be 3 d secure jovi ashton in
two presences for life and djovi worse all
redemption after you know my world 2
representative was written in match of
representing 12 including broadly to
opinions of being wenting go back you do
not track and country that it is the
moment at which the king and wendy's of
tekken from the ring of almost in france to the
two visits and social timely to z like
what they do from the yoyo pink in suspense
be ejected relations in march 3 tracks
one's  for human rights
we live there opposition and a wart hand
of god hand president of course at a
distance
ten thousand times of this cash including
franck in difficulty this coaching wilson
is already punished new tube we have
extremely complex elections and the
indices customs context a bout
time new york the naval set up
around
taking place a beautiful book led to lite
or walls takes 3.9 in 2009 he
associated this summer
yes we have positioned and jive epic to this
rite aid to the opposition dadis one of the
wealthiest savannah statements anti ps
writes a sing what was and drug
6 watt application reminds yes
continuing steam and iron with
washington is natacha
as for natacha gold newmont jewelry
redemption to another we love us  we
fought christian
thank you i have adivasis in time yes
i have a perplexity
it is obvious that mr morel was
responsible for carrying a very harsh and
very severe message to the russian authorities on the
detention of mr nadal nor my
question it is the negative answer  the
end of not receiving from the Russian authorities
deserves that he shortens his visit
since finally the European Union
asks for the release navalni in front of the
release all the people who have been
arrested they are told that it is not
question in my question  is
it that human rights are a
priority for the european union or is
it something that
we actually put in front but
that then  e we do the business for
which mr morel was in charge
of going to moscow
knowing that we have very important subjects to
dissipate the climate etc etc
on which the russians have an
important role and that it was necessary to resume the
dialogue
and is  -is there not a certain
duplicity and is my second question
for nabila actually it is not the
first time that mr morel say
an answer are the penalties that
there is nothing it is very very hard like like
as a precision, that means that the
etams in the member states who say that
they have asked for sanctions are
telling us canards
it is that from the moment the
procedure cannot be launched because
no member state has  made a
request saying here is the list of
people I want to punish for
the arrest of Mr. N'à Mamie we
can't do anything so
the member states have a big
responsibility in the kind of double
game which is that of have done
human rights do not v  We don't do anything to
sanction human
rights violations how do you as
a committee manage that because
after that it's you who will be
forced to go and negotiate with the Russians
I'm sorry Christian I
absolutely understand the meaning of all these
questions but the mission of
the duo representative vice president's trip is
in progress it is up to him to decide at what
time he wishes to put it easy done
bring it to an end or make a
decision other you can not  not
ask us
here to comment on a mission that is
in progress nor on niche on its results
and on the way in which this
policy is carried out even though the
visit is in progress so I propose that
we resume the debate on Monday
once  that the visit will have been completed
that all the elements will be at your
disposal and and to ours giovanni and
Zealander
the mvno mike ok we see an all clause
to survive each visit and roll
move to her family vi  llage natal is
attached health fails sps
today six photos
you can't sweat two important pieces
in this context michael andretti kyle
vanden eynden committee meeting is being
used to be viewed 6 in 10 as andy
specific and few of life protocol for
as you  prisons that they leave
andrist effect in 10 min to urbanize
queens in new york mike leigh anne
nomads hockey verena duarte de flore
by reinaldo bolivar between licha and
fires 10 a.m. at the meeting non voilà so what
is famous back to giovanni
en  effect no case the big men are
seeking appear weak
photo visit seems to be chased
hold in the hands of those who voted
no
we are under cinema did not feel recent
but towards in you we feel or keith hall
have two passes one of steel  it's at
wynau manica these are all my tweets
of long solo stories but
five years ago also lives soa mobile 1525
hamas is very symbolic of may 10 and 11
bannaby there we go down below it
denot  e miss anything morandi
heading north of town a to z
trophies and day or afghan m
between october 2000 and riku and erik
lensherr price carried out
german enemies were unacceptable harm
to willow for supply of return from
people of myanmar
watar kannad all  everything everything is
what is is a place and date discretion
will take place in said when it comes
to flour to do what below the
youyous and kasindi internally beauce
and a brush an enemy and more as well
as in every hour national partners
boots aux soa would like to say that we
do have strong concerns about this curious
legal growl used for hyper president of
lider express lease to represent
statements in 2 59 to brioude fraudsters
and conditional [ __ ] police
along with others have been arrested in
connection with men  and riku yes to
oakland but trout or [ __ ] lies
and the state of emergency the story of
these civilian lives government to open
new electric beds  risks parliament and the
procedures of its psy quintiles menchov
of president vice president and the new
government and the european union expect
the safety of the season of myanmar
a jet member states to be in show time
and we consider that is arranged a
thing of democracy +  25 you will go back
in time to do van emden moving
i will see to that of all
surprises
ayew these two formats and rubino
consider me about this opinion
against a drop of 5.5
no and that is we have two
kachine studios  nabila the time it takes in the
dungeon fanni is at you you were assessed
and we have assessed the situation of m
has rights we decided to go the
baltic states of the situation mesto navalni should
not been president guillou continued to
call immediate and unconditional
release investigations we had
democratic society moreover because it opposes
a scholarship to no 119 100 positions and
not schengen
so we were right here it that way of
never delays in touch with mr eva  ns
estimates 5 the villa
a hitch zinfos974 and death julian
julian white sonia squad sauce
sonia social security negotiations to which s
moving patricia 5th time that eric maria
barcelona other ministers ministers
thing yes to cackling commission of
vaccinated against 9.9 in imax made by
surprise to the public the dates of their life
this is of states government vaccination
since one which is forever of ring 18.6
life supported by many tifosi vaccine
strategy shrink the commission and earn
and envy them this printers and
strategy there is a need and highly
complicated endavant invents on the road
of [ __ ] technique of soft good
creative ideas objective and excavations
to the spectators 10 of commission to
the express not said simply of
strategy yes life
we vaccinate vaccination prison equipped in 2010
ello
eric hello stéphane questions on th
vaccine so now  that
mr morel clearly said that he
hoped that the sputnik vaccine would be
approved quickly and  then i was
could be used in the member states
is the commission thinking about a
group purchase procedure at 8 p.m.
for the 27 as has been the case in
the advanced bar gay games and i was
wondering if at this stage  in the
discussions too much sputnik and the emma we
were now at the stage of the request
for marketing authorization or do we
only remain with the request for scientific opinions
thank you thank you sole the second question
I am afraid that you will have to  the address
to the European Medicines Agency not
to us it is they who can give you
the most precise and up-
to-date information on the contacts they have with
the manufacturers of the scout vaccine
with regard to the  first question, I
'm not going to comment on the words of the representative duo,
which I haven't heard myself,
but I would simply like to
remind you that two things must be distinguished,
moreover, you did it a little bit
in your question and I  thank you
on the one hand the proc  sort of approval process
that must be completed for
a vaccine producer to be able
to place the vaccine it manufactures on the European
market throughout the European market
this
necessarily goes through the
European Medicines Agency can by
marketing authorization by
the european union, that's one thing and
there have been many statements that
have been made, including here by the
european commission, on the fact that
we are inviting the manufacturer of the vaccine to
submit an application  from the
European Medicines Agency with all the
data necessary to be able to obtain
this approval a second thing is
the portfolio of vaccines that the
European Commission and the
Member States have selected have set
up and at present this
portfolio  exist you know that there are
a certain number of negotiations in
progress with other companies and
beyond that we have no
comments to make
it will be their f  come on it's just the I
ask myself this question because from
the moment the vaccine was not authorized
given the delays the two
millions of what can be produced I
tell myself that it can give rise to
fierce competition  between the
member
states would it not be in the commission's best
interest to guard against that by
trying to relaunch a kind of pro
at the collective purchasing procedure
listen to me samuel we have been here very
many times that there are  forums
to discuss this the member states
can discuss it with the
european commission within the framework of the state board
i mean that is not a
question that is emerging here by
us never mind there are forums
discussion to assess the relevance
of the scope of the current portfolio
and the possible need
to expand it to one or another to swell
other manufacturers in the holidays
what is clear is that the
portfolio  current negotiated by the team
negotiation which includes the
commission and certain member states
covers an extremely large number
of doses of vaccines which will make it possible to
vaccinate the whole of the
European population and therefore the question
is rather to know when
we are going to obtain these  doses and you
know it's a debate that occupies us
here including here in the press room on a
daily basis
rather than whether we need
new additional doses of a
new from a new manufacturer
but that says the door  is never
closed in principle but there are
forums in which this must be
discussed
where can be discussed
we remain on the question of vaccines
I give the floor to susanna white house
in extremis their life date manufacturing
men and vaccine and complex processes
where they go
indeed many many different eight
particularly important
we keep you close my hand steinmann
china in order to ensher date where lives my
nature the vaccine ce have access  to be
necessary like paint it and
context clues date 10 president asas thierry
breton pierre gattaz later and if he
says yes on board thônex and our
productions can vaccinate 72 talecris
on a reader in date level which have
monetary and francesco clauses  passage
under a fallois tailor but well
said one of the stands playable you what you
say that is it would do they are not
* sodexo said without news of what
you were who has no figure they
say of figure  de rice would have said
company out of the t-shirts
susanna yes bay south wales online is
left-handed ride with the company's in juneau
and nome contact with the company is now
we have seen in this week's sale
evans cannon falls we can't I am
saddened 2010  vaccine entre high stake
in ways to buy in france in contact with
vie manufacture fort past life my
partner jasmin vaccine tignes where tony
vairelles this fiasco
in france
the mic is activated
whole weekend you so we move to
isabelle ory sorry i have a camera problem
i would like to come back to this task force
i read the interview with mrs von der
leyen in the cross this morning she
recognizes that it was a problem that
was underestimated that  it should have been dealt with
earlier and therefore but it
does not explain why in fact we
underestimated that is what it is it is
collective is it the
member states that should have s
it's true that it's quite striking
that hasn't been thought about I don't know
we could even imagine from the summer on
production capacities and their
riespach imagine that they an attack
against a factory in the  sinn de puurs for
example I cross my fingers but I
mean we find ourselves deprived of
campsas team had this reflection
six months ago quite simply thank you for
your question
it is all the reflection which is carried out
around the concept of the new agency
r16 slope and john if what the
president refer to it  is the
fact that in europe we do
n't have we don't yet have
we are working on it
the institutional tools in place
to be able to respond
instantly to a crisis of this kind
unlike in relation to the united states
with barda, that is linked to the nature of
the european union
to the competences which are devolved to
and as you know the european union
advances each time by learning from the
crises which those  which are developing and by
developing the appropriate tools,
so that's one thing, you can't
just suddenly, at the level of
the European Union,
instantly develop a whole
policy making it possible to increase and
secure production when there is
there is no institutional tool to
do this we had to create from
scratch and we did it
extremely quickly a
European European approach if only
to be able to buy vaccines
because that is  a priori of
national competence but a virus
knows no borders and therefore the
Member States and the
European Commission very quickly
agreed on the fact that we had to
act to buy vaccines
together, it is  already a significant step forward
which brings the
European Commission really to the limit of the
competences which can be
attributed to it and by using I remind you of
all the available margins of the
European budget which was what it was
in the last year of the
multiannual financial framework  so that's a
first thing the second thing is
that we negotiated contracts
with companies on the basis in particular of a
criterion which was their
vaccine production capacity and that's
why we also modulated the  number
of doses that was requested from one
producer compared to another
depending precisely on this
production capacity so obviously
it's always easy  e after a posteriori
to say
to ourselves we should have done this we should have done that we
recognize that
[Music]
we should have followed very
carefully but we didn't
really have the tools don't forget to dry
down if this industrial scheme and  that's
why we are now putting in
place a structure that will prepare for
the future it is the third task of
this task force to prepare for the future to
prepare the other difference
barioz defense as we say in English
and in the meantime  to work with
entrepreneurs with
flagship companies including manufacturers on
production in the very short term to
avoid
bottlenecks and secondly to
work on variants quentin yes
hello eric it's just to come back
to this story of  agents pour l'adar
part I read correctly the
public consultation was launched on January 27
on the creation is announced and at the
level of the calendar if I
understood correctly it is t  still supposed to be
finally presented the text of the commission
is supposed to arrive in the last quarter
of 2010 21 why whereas now
we have a cost but of strangulation that there
is a task force which was set up that
Mr. Breton you have not decided
to  advance this calendar
I cannot answer you directly on
the dates but I think that it is
necessary to realize that the
situation is evolving and therefore
we will certainly have the opportunity to
come back to this subject later
there  there are other questions for us
today
on this subject i don't see any
on other subjects david
sorry i have an audio problem i hope
it all works out question competition
a well so if he is there this  week
there were several meetings between the
representatives of alitalia and the dg
competition there was a discussion I
believe by telephone where they were announced
in the calendar between the
vice-president besta gué and the
italian minister walter
so  i wanted to know firstly if
a rideout of the discussion between veste
à guéret equal terry and cie have they
discussed alitalia and if there is any
news on the file thank you
major bodies david r i hope that now
then in relation to the meeting  that he
had and minister arcand say that
they discussed the two-tonne
crown so I don't want to add
anything more specific
there is nothing new on the
files you know very well we are  in
contact with the Italian authorities on
the 2.6 in general we cannot
give more detailed information
now thanks to are there any other
questions competition david pollock
yes has there been no
notification of  the part of the
Italian government of the fact that habitat finally in
a decree there are 200 million more
for alitalia as that we
only provide the guide etc
nothing I have no news on the 200
million either as you know  we
have already called two  support measures
for the compensation for the
damage caused for the coc empties the
hen and games in september and november
game hearing about the other day
in the seine
is that if we are in contact with the
italian authorities on a third
measure  of compensation
it was 2 after 73 million I think out of
the 200 million which for which you have
already asked for some information the
sorting days we saw the comments of the
press did not lead to specific comments
you know very well that
it is for  the member states to see
pellets able to this concerns
leds which must be notified to the
commission
as always we are ready to discuss
with the member states to see if the
public support measures are in
line with the rules on
aid  state
thank you other questions competition
can nothing eh I do not see there are
other subjects for us today
this is not the case either so thank you
very much I wish you u  n
relaxing weekend and we will meet you with
pleasure on Monday here in the press room have a nice
weekend